everybody's talking about big data many
different fields like
finances physics biology medicine and
many more
they're all talking about big data and
all you can do uh
with it right but my question is are
they really doing big data in a previous
video my opinion student review was
talking about what is big data and
trying to define it and one of the main
issues we
have at the minute is that there is a
standard definition of what big data
actually is also another issue is the
many phases that big data may have so
for example you might be thinking of how
to acquire that data right so installing
different sensors and how to get that
data
and how to store that data that's a
different aspect to it right so
the computational infrastructure how to
keep it secure
and the area i'm more interested in is
how to analyze how to mine how to try to
extract knowledge
of that big data using machine learning
and data science
techniques
how much data is big data how many
megabytes gigabyte terabytes
so it's actually really difficult or
almost impossible to answer
uh that question there isn't a standard
definition but there is one definition i
want to read out for you because i find
it
quite quite good in my in my opinion big
data involves
data with volume diversity and
complexity requires
new techniques algorithms and analysis
to extract
valuable knowledge which is going to be
typically hidden
right so if you are having a really big
spreadsheet let's say for example covet
cases right that kind of case that oh
i don't have any other column in that
expression it's not big data yeah
not quite big data if you're using a
very
uh cool machine learning algorithm from
the scikit-learn library
from with python it might not be big
data either
right so is it 20 megabytes is one
terabyte this all depends
on what you need to do with that
particular data set right so you might
be using
a very simple algorithm to do account
so for that you might have a really huge
data set and you can do it with your
with a laptop so it might not be even
big data
but if you need to run a genetic
algorithm to
find out uh whatever and optimize
whatever parameters for a deep
learning algorithm well they might it
might be that the data
it cannot be that big anyways right
because you are not going to be able to
do it with one computer
so simply put big data in my opinion is
when you need
more than one computer to be able to
deal with the data
it's also very important to remember
that what we call big data today might
be almost nothing tomorrow right so
computers are evolving and we have more
and more memory every day and the
ability to process and compute more
and faster so you might think today
one gig of data might be a lot but maybe
that tomorrow is
almost nothing right so the definition
cannot be just
precisely an amount of data it's not
about the volume
it's much more than that it's when you
need that answer and how you need that
analysis of what kind of analysis you
need to be doing
so sean how much data do you think we
have at the minute
in the world in the world yeah i thought
you meant on this uh
sd card that i've been recording what
happens after terror is it better what
happens after yeah
and then you got more and more and more
right so i think there's going to be a
lot of zeros on there
a lot of seedless there so at the
beginning of 2020
the digital universe was estimated to be
44 zettabytes of data but i'm not so
sure how accurate that figure is right
but
what it means is we are actually
collecting data all the time
and somehow we are a little bit under
the impression that having
more data and having data is the new
kind of the new goal
and everybody wanted it right and is
that for sure
something that we need do we really need
to collect data for the sake of it
and that might be something for another
video but that's something else how
sustainable
is to keep storing data just for for the
fun of it but
what i want to do today is to okay let's
say we want to store data
how do we do it how we can analyze that
data it's about the quality of the data
right it's all about the quality it's
not about the quantity right so
sometimes the problem is we don't know
where the quality is
and therefore we need to gather the data
collect it
and then use pre-processing techniques
to be able to shrink that data and just
get that that is of
good quality some people call it smart
data
it's like running for gold isn't it yeah
exactly
exactly all right so how do we deal with
big data so let's say shown that you've
got you know
you've got a data set and you want to do
something and you're running some
machine learning and you've got your
computer at home right and you're a very
lucky guy and you've got 16
gigs off run and you've got one terabyte
of
drive and you're running there your
favorite machine learning algorithm
let's say that you're running
random forest you're trying to do some
things and analysis with your
data you've got here your data and
you're trying to run
random forest and all of a sudden what
you get is
out of memory right what do you do
uh well you restart
yeah oh sorry i've been using windows
too long that's the problem if you're if
you're using
windows that's your own mistake right so
you should be using something else to
make sure that you don't get that
message but let's assume that it's not
the problem
a good computer scientist would probably
say i'm going to try to optimize the
memory utilization of my algorithm but
probably you're using some library to
run this random forest right so you
don't really know the
implementation details of that
particular library so
you try to run that and you say oh damn
it i think i will probably need a little
bit more memory so what you do
is you go and buy some more and then you
say i'm gonna get
64 gigabytes of ram then you run it
everything goes well happy days
everybody happy and this is what we call
scale up or vertical scalability
so scale up vertical scalability is
real good when it works right so if you
can just simply buy a little bit more
memory if you have
enough money that's all good but there
will be a limit you will not be able to
go
above that limit right so 64 what if
then
later on that data set becomes even
bigger and then you try again and you
say out of memory again
are you gonna go and buy 128 or 256 i
mean if you're rich maybe you want to
try
but you might not be able to do it right
but whenever possible
if you're gonna stick to this approach
please by all means
scale up all the time that's what we
want to do because it will be more
efficient
in terms of energy as well consumption
and anything what is the solution
if we cannot do it with one single
computer well that sure is when you
bring in a second or third or fourth ah
exactly so
rather than using one single computer
what you're going to do is to use
a few of them how do we call this
a server phone scale up
this is gonna be scale out or
horizontal scalability
right so we're gonna try to spread the
computational cost of whatever analysis
whatever algorithm you're running
across a number of computers so
basically
a divide and conquer approach and you
might be thinking oh that's fantastic
and so what is
the problem with that that's brilliant
right yeah but there are a few issues
you need to bear in mind
so the first thing is here when you're
using one single computer you're going
to be able to use your random forest
from
the scikit-learn library right straight
away or from any
programming language you're using but if
you've got a few computers
you need to bear in mind they are all
independent they all have their own
hard drive for solid state drive they
have their own run memory here
right and and they can be helping
to solve the analysis that you want to
do but you need to explicitly
and in some way design that distributed
computing and that is big data whenever
we need to distribute the
computing we need to think how to use
multiple computers
to be able to use it the problem is
you've got to use a network for
communication
across those computers and that is
actually really expensive
and a network equipment is expensive and
also it becomes
the main bottleneck sometimes because
we're gonna be moving data
around all the time right so another
issue of this
and it doesn't come for free to doing
this to be doing this
scale out is space you need more
computers
and also energy and actually you might
be thinking they're they're just
standard desktop computer but they're
not they're normally
well you know racks of computers and you
might be thinking isa you're talking
about hpc right high performance
computing yes that's what i'm talking
about right so
yes you can put all of them you have to
put the network it's going to be more
costly but it allows you to do
quite a few things the first thing that
allows you is if the data keeps growing
you simply need to add in one more
machine
to the mix right so you simply put one
more machine and you're able to cope
with more and more data
as you go which is good and it's going
to be cheaper than upgrading
um your own computer there is one more
thing that is quite interesting from the
big data point of view
to do a scale out so imagine you have
really powerful machine
you're running your deep learning
algorithm there right
and but it takes a little bit long
because it's a lot of data
and it takes let's say 18 days
to get that sorted and after day 17
something goes wrong crush it and you
need to start off from the very
beginning
if you were able to design a distributed
solution to run the same algorithm
if one of these computers crashes
you can still restart that operation in
that in there
and manage to get the result faster than
with one single computer and that's what
we call in big data
the ability to deal with faults right so
it's full
tolerance that is one of the key aspects
we want to keep in mind
when we are designing distributed
solutions for uh
big data all right so you might be
saying okay i said what you're talking
about here is
high performance computing right and
that's no surprise you're dealing with
loads of data
and therefore you need to you really
really need to use multiple computers to
do so
and that's very true but traditionally
those hpc's
you're going to have multiple computers
each one of them with their own
hdd or solid state drive their own ram
memory their own operating system as
well
typically it's going to be a linux
server as well they are connected
through a network and
also there is one more network that
allows you
to have a central storage so
typically what you normally have or what
we used to have traditionally in hpc
is a relatively small input data right
so you've got your input data here this
small square that i'm drawing here
and what's going to happen is that this
one will
be loaded in main memory in all of those
computers
in there right and then what they do is
they do some sort of computation here
and what they used to do this kind of
imagine for example any optimization
algorithm
trying to solve some big optimization
problem or simulation and stuff like
that what they do is they use this
infiniband to share
those computations across computers to
solve the bigger problem
but what happened if instead of having
this small piece of data you've got
loads of this what do you think is going
to happen sean
well that data's going to get shifted
around a lot yeah so now
the problem with big data that i also
like to call big data
data intensive applications is that
they're going to spend most of their
time
reading and writing right so they will
need to read from here
and load this one here so this one here
will go here then here then here
and the same thing so what's going to
happen is this network
will crash it will not be able to cope
with the amount of data and that is
moving across the network
so when you have a big data application
a traditional hpc cluster
will not do the trick we need something
else
what do we need
bigger hard disks yeah well actually we
do have a
really huge central storage which is
normally really expensive
so what is the solution we've got the
hdds here
all this well maybe if you're lucky
solid
straight drive and there right so what
we could do is to try to make a better
use of those
and that's what it makes instead of a
hpc
cluster it's going to be a big data
cluster so a big data cluster will look
exactly the same
but now we're going to be using the hard
drives then representing down here
so we're gonna have multiple computers
i'm gonna just throw three of them
each one of them with their own hard
drive and here
what you can do is to spread the data
across
the different computers imagine a really
big data set well
the hello world for big data is always
counting the words
that you've got in a very big file so
imagine i have a big file
um and i'm gonna try to split that
into well let's say six pieces right so
i have
here i'm going to have the first chunk
the third one the fourth
the fifth and one again what you want to
do
is to keep all the computation
happening just locally in those drives
so what you want to do is to get that
big data set
spread across a number of computers
rather than having it in a central
storage
disconnected by networks so this is not
a good idea in big data you want to keep
it
locally and something i i did on purpose
and do you notice i have this number one
here and this number one here
representing for example just a chunk of
the same
file why do you think i did this was it
for fault
exactly exactly exactly imagine that
this machine crashes
so this piece of the data we want to
make sure is somewhere available
so you can still process it right so
that is obviously what you want to do
so this is basically
a way to create a distributed file
system a file system that will
transparently and by that i mean you
don't really need to care about the
details
underneath in that file system you
simply say
this machine says i want to access a
or i want to access one i just access it
and i have it
locally and that is what we call in big
data the principle
of data locality try to keep
the data you're going to be using
locally in every single machine and
that's what distinguishes
a big data cluster from standard
hpc cluster right so that's the key
thing
uh to to make it work and and that is
actually the main
motto of this mapreduce paradigm that
rebecca actually explained in another
video
which is all about the idea of moving
computation
is cheaper than moving computation and
data at the same time what you want to
do
is to apply an operation yeah through
all the data the how you don't really
care about
which machine is doing it you don't
really care about it either
you simply want to run your analysis and
you want to get it done
quickly and efficiently and for that you
want to avoid
input output data going through the
network and that's what you want to do
using a big data technology like
apache hadoop and apache part we will
see in future videos
it would put this into what's called a
key value pair so we're going to take
each word
as the key so for each word within this
we'll
map it so that the word's the key and
then we put the number function through
the use of tree
gaussians and giving me
this three peaks in the distribution
showing